ja mein thema ist dass es in den letzten
monaten und jahren ein verzerrtes bild
der jugend gab obwohl wir es eigentlich
immer besser wussten die shell
jugendstudie hat immer gesagt die jugend
ist nicht nur voraussetzung schafft
sondern da gehen hauptsächlich
abiturienten und studenten demonstrieren
aber die jugend ist viel vielfältiger
und trotzdem haben wir im wahlkampf aber
erlebt dass es ein quasi ein bild der
jugend gezeichnet würde das sich
hauptsächlich in
weltuntergangsszenarien verzichte button
und moralischen klimadebatte nach
hochgesetzt wurde bis dahin dass wir
über die debatte der enkel wie vor
diskutiert haben das ist jung gegen alt
gegen wird gebe und die jungen doch
jetzt endlich ihre großeltern überzeugen
müssen damit wir noch die welt retten
und es gab klimaaktivisten die quasi an
wahl angehen teilgenommen wohl so wurde
das bild zum teil in den medien von der
jugend gezeichnet und wir wussten das
ist eigentlich anders ist und dass erst
wieder ergebnis hat es auch gezeigt
zuerst mit ergebnis hat ja gezeigt dass
die stärkste kraft meine partei die fdp
sogar geworden ist und dass die
jugendhilfe diverser ist diejenigen die
vor dann das bild immer von der jungen
gezeichnet haben hatten dann nur noch
thema und sport auf einmal übrig da hat
da wurde dann gesagt das bildungssystem
hätte versagt das seien alles kreuz wir
hätten da ein neoliberales leistungs
verständnis und der da gab es nur nach
hemer und sport christian lindner wurde
kritisiert als für eine falsch
verstandene profi äußerung aber jetzt
jungen menschen zum teil fiel ihr
wahlverhalten zu kritisieren ist
eigentlich von doppelmoral nicht zu
übertreffen ich finde das sollte sich
jetzt ändern und wir sollten anerkennt
dass die jung vielfältiger ist und nicht
jeder junger menschen eine schublade
passt ja wer richtig erstens ist
deutschland nicht der prenzlauer berg
sondern das ist auch heidenheim und
passau und was weiß ich was ja sehr
vielfältiges land mit sehr vielfältigen
kulturen ländern grössenordnungen
lebenszielen unterschiedlich geprägten
menschen zweitens geht das was ich jetzt
hier beklagen natürlich nur mit bestimmt
geprägten medien das ist das ist der
glaube ich der schlüsselfaktor das ist
ja auch gemessen worden dass in den
medien die redakteure die dort arbeiten
sind zu einem weit überwiegenden teil
ich habe jetzt die genauen zahlen nicht
kommen
und der stern der sich finde ich
besonders
absolut das ist ja auch heftig
diskutiert worden das mit mit der
bewegung gemeinsam eine ausgabe geleitet
wurde das kann nicht die aufgabe von
journalisten sein und zu ticken aber
viele große medien die sind halt
eindeutig politisch gestrickt und auch
persönlich die journalisten die das tun
und schreiben in die richtung und und
befördern die bewegung und befördern das
bild einer jugend die ihnen gefällt und
ich musste aber dann durchgehend
erklären den letzten eineinhalb wochen
haben so viele journalisten gefragt und
wollten ja alle darüber berichten weil
es gibt ja nur sondierungsgespräche weil
man nichts hört oder das erste
ergebnisse berichten konnten durfte ich
dann immer erklärt spielen und die sind
halt überraschte man den sagt ja das
erste eigene auto im ländlichen raum ist
ein freiheits gefördert oder das ist das
ist wirklich wichtig für die und es gibt
ganz viele junge menschen die wissen
dass die altersvorsorge nicht mehr
staatlich funktioniert und sie gesichert
sind und ja die investieren
aktiengeschäften sich damit und dann kam
eigentlich da auch wieder nur so ein
bisschen spott und deswegen finde ich
eigentlich gut dass diese debatte ich
freue mich natürlich dass die über die
fdp dann auch geführt wird aber ich
finde die debatte grundsätzlich einfach
auch richtig dann diverses haben ein
gefühl dafür jetzt sind ja wahnsinnig
viele junge leute in den bundestag
eingezogen bei der spd-fraktion sind
glaube ich 50 der jungsozialisten wieder
jetzt drinnen sitzen in der fraktion was
das für was das für junge abgeordnete
sind wie ist das bei ihnen wie ist das
vielleicht soweit sie schon gesehen
haben wir anderen fraktionen also bei
der grünen jugend und bei den jusos
würde ich sagen dass es klar war
linksruck den man da noch mal
verzeichnen konnte bei den jüngeren
personen eingegangen auch nicht damit
gerechnet bei den jusos ist sehr genau
so dass ihr glaube ich mit allen ihren
usern mitgliedern quasi die ampel
mehrheit verhindern konnten also wenn
alle mit nein stimmen hatte dafür keine
mehrheit jusos eindeutig dagegen stimmen
da ich noch nicht mal der linkspartei
musste frage
vorher geht bevor diese sanierung
begonnen haben ist ja schon am morgen
nach der bundestagswahl ist ja die fdp
schon beschimpft worden und zwar aus dem
kreis der spd-vorsitzenden ja als voodoo
ökonomie ökonomen und
und was war dann luft die kussfreunde
öfter für richtig wenn der mieter sogar
noch ein ja ja aber das ist ja auch sony
und besonders pikant in das wie es das
bei den liberalen sind da auch den
hardcore neoliberalen jugendlichen
eingezogen ist den sind die jungen
liberalen auch die die hayek jünger
schlechthin ich erkläre mir ganz kurz
den unterschied zwischen hardcore
neoliberal und liberal na das ist ja
ohnehin den kampfbegriff also muss ich
kann nicht erklären
nein aber ich wollte ja ich sage auch
das hat mich das buch gelesen berufsbild
hinaus wenn die anderen
jugendorganisationen sozusagen immer den
radikalen flügel ihrer jeweiligen partei
widerspiegeln wäre mal interessant was
bei den liberalen nachgezogen ist so
divers wie die jugend ist so diversen
die jungen liberalen das sind wirklich
überzeugte marktwirtschaftler auch mit
eingezogen haben ja mehrere junge
abgeordnete bekommen da sind aber
sicherlich auch bei einiger eingezogen
aber das ist ja vielleicht auch eine
form von radikalität im liberalismus die
sich wahrscheinlich eher den sozialen
liberalismus zu ordnern also durchaus
divers und ich glaube das tut aber auch
eigentlich an den jugendorganisationen
immer gut wenn sie auch die wir
unterstellen wäre die koalition kommt so
zustande wie jetzt die sondierungen
laufen also ampel regiert was passiert
dann aus den linken flügel dieser
fraktionen mit der fdp in kiel das ist
halt das rote tuch ihr seid die
neoliberalen ihr wollt die reichen immer
reicher machen das kennt man diese
parolen kennen wir alle wie geht es dann
da der fdp oder stehen da jetzt die
neuen bündnispartner die grüne führung
auf seiten der fdp wie belastbar ist das
also ich beteilige mich sonst wenig an
was wäre wenn spekulationen aber
vielleicht zu den grünen da hat man es
beim bundesparteitag schon gesehen dass
die grüne jugend sich mit keiner
einzigen änderungsantrag durchgesetzt
hat am ende beim awa programm er hatte
hp schon striktes register und hat dort
sein sein ziel durchgezogen haben das
zur analyse bei der grünen jugend bei
den jusos der spd ja bekanntlich anders
herum gewesen man hat ja die kevin
kühnert theodor jetzt total auch schon
einige gesehen aber ich glaube das schon
auch in der spd macht gewinn für olaf
scholz am ende durch eine erfolgreiche
wahl entstanden ist und bei den jusos
muss man noch mal ein bisschen
differenzieren da gibt es tatsächlich
auch ein paar die nicht ganz am linken
rand der partei sind aber es gibt halt
noch den linken flügel der dazu kommt
man also es bleibt auf jeden fall
spannend aber am ende siegt ja sehr
häufig fraktionszwang auch in den
parteien letztlich den überrascht das
ergebnis das nun doch nicht alle geräte
to work fans sind
ja ein dass die fdp dann tatsächlich
vorne war bei der jugend hat mich
überrascht aber ich habe nie den abstand
so groß gesehen weil klar für die jungen
ist klima ein wichtiges thema aber
genauso digitalisierung startup
mentalität klar punkte für die für die
fdp und die fdp hat ja auch kein
schlechtes klima programm also sagen ja
viele des windows konsequent durchsetzt
wo es ist es so theoretisch
erfolgreicher hat weniger weil grün
untergangsszenarien mehr
also mir war es gibt junge menschen die
villen und wegen dieses kinderprogramm
ja und ich glaube die beiden parteien
gelb und grün bieten einfach aktuell
jugendlichen ein besseres angebot als es
die sozialdemokraten tun die auf rente
und mindest
[Musik]